how many of us have said in our culture
regardless of where you are an income
what your ratios are I can afford the
payment that's an easy payment that's
now I can do that
I know a bunch of people say that
because the average car payment America
today is five hundred to six dollars
over 84 months according the National
Auto Dealers Association so the average
car payments but the average household
income being fifty nine thousand the
average car payment is five hundred and
six dollars now I don't know where you
live but I live in Tennessee and five
hundred six dollars if you didn't pay it
in a payment and you put it in a shoebox
in ten months you would look down and
there would be five thousand dollars in
that shoebox ten times 500 is five
thousand so if you can afford the
payment you can afford to save up and
pay cash for a five thousand dollar car
on average in America today every ten
months so let's do it for ten months by
five thousand our car what can you buy
for five thousand bucks
hmm pretty good old used Camry might be
ugly but might be mechanically okay
pretty good old used may be a Honda Lowe
Honda Accord it's my bean
maybe a 90s vintage but you could do it
for five grand right and you'll get a
lot of life left in those cars get you
know pickup for five grand it wouldn't
be pretty but it might be that might be
mechanically good right I know I can buy
one for that I just I just sold one for
3,000 the other day that was here that
we paid three thousand for ten years ago
and drove it ten years here at the
office for delivery and then we just
sold it for three thousand and then
amazing so um you know that kind of
stuffs out there right now do you want
to drive that crap the rest of your life
I don't drive crappy cars I want you to
live like no one else so later you can
live like no one else right but if you
did that for ten months and you you you
bought a car for cash for five thousand
dollars and then you drove that for ten
months ten
it's later you'd have another $5,000
wouldn't you in your shoebox by the way
you know how much a $5,000 Honda goes
down in ten months and value doesn't my
effect if you bought it right it might
be worth six and you might only paid
five for it so you can sell it for five
and you got five in your shoebox but you
have a $10,000 car then 20 months in
that you paid cash for you know and
let's put ten let's put $500 in the
shoebox again for ten more months and
let's sell your ten thousand dollar car
now ten more months later for ten
thousand dollars because you paid ten
thousand for it and it doesn't go down
much in value in ten months and you've
got another five thousand dollars in
there in that shoebox now you got
fifteen thousand dollars we're only 30
months in and you're driving a 15
thousand dollar paid for in cash car and
you never borrowed a dime thirty months
is two and a half years and I didn't ask
you to walk during that time or uber or
ride the bus or anything else you were
driving a car the entire time you just
paid cash you saved up and paid for it
which is what you got to do folks I mean
you just have to get your head around if
I don't have the money that means I
can't afford it I think I might be able
to pay the payments if I don't get laid
off or another kids get sick doesn't
really mean I can afford it that's a set
of assumptions and when you sit on your
assumptions you will you'll have trouble
don't do that don't do that save up and
pay for things in that way you know how
much even if you do a bad purchase when
you pay for it in cash see how much it
hurts not nearly as much but try paying
payments on something that was stupid oh
my goodness every month you have this
reminder that says you're stupid you're
stupid you're stupid just like last
month you're stupid again and now you're
stupid again I pay payments on stuff
like that man I just hated that reminder
it's like a little parrot and then
corner in my wallet you're stupid you're
stupid that's what that payment does
once a month you're immature
you didn't have the ability to delay
pleasure children do what feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it